martin loizillon bonjour merci d'être
ici aux grandes écuries à versailles
nous allons parler de plein de choses de
votre jeune carrière je vais néanmoins
très bien rempli et donc il ya plein de
choses à dire déjà vous allez jouer le
30 juin
ici il renversa voile à l'école des
femmes
polygone et liam et vous jouez le rôle
de ra's voilà et donc vous allez
clôturer le festival du mot molière avec
cette pièce oui voila moi j'aimerais
remonter un petit peu dans le temps pour
faire mieux connaissance avec vous même
si maintenant plein de gens vous colère
mais bon quand même on va creuser
j'ai appris que vous étiez versaillais
âgées j'ai grandi j'ai fait le premier
de ma vie à versailles
je suis resté à versailles jusqu'à l'âge
de 6-7 ans d'accord tu vécu à vue de
saint cloud à versailles et puis je suis
allé à l'école du lit très bien d'accord
bon ensuite aller à paris oui voilà
et on vous avait commencé à prendre des
cours de théâtre sur toi oui voilà en
arrivant à paris j'ai commencé à faire
du théâtre au théâtre du petit monde à
plouay avec nicolas rigas et puis voilà
si on veut dire ha oui et à l'époque il
anime et les îles il anime et aussi des
classes des cours et voilà c'est comme
ça que j'ai commencé à faire du théâtre
d'accord et justes en aparté le théâtre
du petit monde alors on peut expliquer
ce que ça fait le théâtre du petit monde
s'est alors c'est une très vieille
structure de théâtral qui a été créé en
1919 elle avait au début comme
pour vocation de faire exclusivement des
spectacles pour enfants spectacles jeune
public des contes pour enfants
opérateurs française
et puis quand nicolas rigas a récupéré
la direction de la compagnie lui c'est
plutôt tourné vers des spectacles
familiaux et donc on crée maintenant des
spectacles quand donc beaucoup de
classiques molière on a fait beau marché
voilà et puis on continue aussi la
création spectacle pour enfants là je
sais avec le théâtre du petit monde dont
j'ai créé le petit chaperon rouge voilà
voilà alors ce fameux petit chaperon
rouge que vous avez créés il a une
histoire aussi avec versailles
oui en fait la première fut la première
fois que j'ai créé c'était je crois il
ya deux ans
au moins molière on arrive à
l'université interâges donc ça a été la
première création qu'on a fait et puis
j'ai repris ce spectacle l'année
dernière on a joué au festival d'avignon
on vient de jouer toute une saison à
paris à la comédie saint michel pont
et puis on part en tournée et on va
jouer notamment à casablanca
l'hiver prochain oui ok donc ça c'est
une chose
après donc vous avez poursuivre au cours
de théâtre oui à quel moment vous ai dit
je vais faire ma carrière je ne sais pas
bien en fait on me disait que c'était
faux possible d'en faire un métier
ouais et donc
à l'adolescence je me suis dit quand
j'aurai mon diplôme mon baccalauréat
j'aurais envie de tenter l'aventuré
fairy tail et puis les choses se sont
enchaînées très vite en fait puisque je
suis j'ai passé mon bac
après mon bac j'ai préparé le concours
du conservatoire national et je suis
rentré délà de la baie le premier de la
première fois en fait alors avant de
passer le concours du conservatoire
national de paris
vous avez passé une année aux etats-unis
à plus d'une année j'ai passé trois ans
et demi quatre ans principalement j'ai
fait tout mon lycée là-bas en fait
d'accord il fait toute ma scolarité de
lycéens la base est là bas j'ai intégré
une formation qui est le stéphanois
oscillateurs qui est une compagnie de
théâtre qui a créé john malkovich ok
voilà qui à la fois produit des
spectacles et des spectacles ils ont un
lieu à théâtrale à chicago et puis aussi
propose des formations aux acteurs sur
audition dans c'était une belle aventure
et une bonne formation mais voilà et du
coup vous avez eu votre procès
l'abattoir les doigts dans le nez je
sais pas si c'est comme ça qu'on a à g a
travaillé en revenant à paris c'est pas
le même c'est quand même voilà vous avez
eu des professeurs assez prestigieux
torreton mesguich oui j'ai travaillé que
philippe torreton daniel mesguich et
nada strancar et philippe duclos
d'accord il fait partie de la même
classe que pierre niney pierre niney on
attendait qu'on vend 100 mais je suis de
la même promo que stanley weber
oui canine était une promo juste en
dessous de moi a déclaré
mais on a on avait en fait à l'époque où
j'étais au conservatoire c'est un petit
peu changé maintenant les promos étaient
étaient toutes réunies en fait on avait
deux courants semble d'accord
donc ça c'est pour la partie scolaire
entre guillemets formation après vous
avez très vite jouée finalement passé
votre premier rôle au cinéma
c'est en 2008 c 130 et bras c'est dans
tes bras dans tes bras bat tera c'est la
juste au moment où j'ai juste après
avoir passé l'audition du conservatoire
et passer une audition pour ce pour ce
film que j'ai fait et c'était formidable
parce que c'était un long métrage de
cinéma c'était avec michèle laroque et
c'était un premier rôle et
bon voilà comme on dit c'est en forgeant
qu'on devient forgeron oui j'étais en
plein dans l'effort est là et après vous
avez eue l'année d'après un autre rôle
important dans après mais c'est ça j'ai
tourné après je fais après mais j'ai
travaillé avec raoul ruiz aussi les
mystères de lisbonne dernier film de
rendre hui tout ça on parallèle avec le
conservatoire
allawi par chance à l'époque où j'étais
au conservatoire on avait la possibilité
de demander pour certains prennent des
décisions j'ai lu tiers nec ça c'était
une grande chance soit d'accord vous
n'êtes pas n'importe où d'ailleurs parce
qu'on a parlé de vous très récemment
grâce au film d'emmanuelle bercot oui la
tête haute
oui oui qui a fait l'ouverture de cannes
oui vous avez joué alors je vous laisse
parler un petit peu vous avez joué qui
donc en fait c'est un film sur la
justice pour mineurs on faire quand un
jeune délinquant et je jouais un jeune
procureur voilà c'est vrai je vois là
oui on peut dire que vous avez 25 ans
oui et demi oui voilà donc effectivement
ces jeunes donc un procureur qui sort de
l'école voilà c'est ça la etc film a
fait l'ouverture il a fait l'ouverture
du festival de cannes il a eu un beau un
beau succès auprès du public et de la
presse y avait des nations autour mais
c'était non ça c'est un film
dont je suis fier d'avoir participé
décor est ce que c'est un film
voilà c'est un film qui parle aussi de
notre société qui parlent de manière
assez intelligente
est-ce que c'est trés c'est et réaliste
et cinématographique en même temps
rennes
donc c'était une belle aventure et puis
du coup c'était sympa de d'inaugurer ce
film à cannes et dans la seine c'est une
belle aventure
donc vous jouez aussi pour la télévision
pendant des films pour la télévision à
savoir la série un village français
oui un village un village français mais
voilà alors à côté moi vous faites quoi
dans ses bras c'est une série qui a été
créé par france télévisions qui retrace
la seconde guerre mondiale mais à
travers le prisme d'un village français
est donc en fait c'est de vivre la
guerre non pas dans la grande histoire
mais dans la petite histoire de deux
français à l'époque
et moi j'ai intégré la série en saison 5
oui chaque saison étant une année de la
guerre dacca et moi j'ai intégré donc la
saison pendant l'année 43 hockey voilà
le thème c'était le service du travail
obligatoire donc où des jeunes français
devait partir travailler en allemagne
pour participer à l'effort de guerre et
moi refusant de partir je me retrouve
clandestins et puis me retrouvant que le
destin je me retrouve résistant à
rejoindre la résistance à peu par la
force des choses il ya pas tellement le
choix
voilà c'est tout ça le thème de la série
c2 par des petits dés finalement des
petits détails font la grande histoire
d'accord et du coup vous avez tourné la
saison 6 là on a tourné la saison 6 ils
ont diffusé une première partie de la
saison en novembre
ils vont finir la diffusion je pense à
la rentrée prochaine
hélas le thème de cette saison c'est le
nez 44 donc c'est la libération c'est
un peu le début de l'épuration voilà ses
doigts sait séduire ces poignante mais
assez violente ouais bon et la 7e et la
septième saison sera la dernière l'année
45 et là ça sera l'année des grands
procès et plus bas le retour à la vie
normale à la politique
j'avais dit aux normales en tout cas
voilà comment q qu'est ce qui se passe
quand tous ces gens qui étaient
résistants se retrouve au pouvoir
d'accord ok donc ça c'est pour la
télévision cinéma on en a parlé sans et
marc vous avez encore deux projets de
films qui ont été tournés mais qui vont
sortir à la rentrée j'imagine suivent un
suiveur va sortir à la rentrée donc
c'est un film qui a été réalisé par ses
premiers films de jeunes réalisateurs
qui s'appelle 1000 wii et c'est
l'histoire de deux jeunes lycéens qui
ont commis un crime par
sans mobile et c'est un peu un film à la
fois qui mélange à la fois le on va dire
le le côté policier du film parce qu'il
ya un meurtre et des gens recherchent
qui a tué et puis à côté philosophique
du film sur sk crime sans mobile est un
crime
est-ce que voilà les casses et des
lycéens qui sont pris en fait dans cet
engrenage dans cet engrenage
philosophique qui les a amenés à faire
des horaires d'accord et c'est rigolo
parce que là vous jouez un tout jeune la
joue alice et après avoir joué un
procureur de 25 ans exactement là comme
quoi on pouvait tout faire c'est
merveilleux et donc c'est un film qui
sortira à la rentrée mais qu'a fait pas
mal de festivals voilà n'aiderait je
vais revenir il a eu un prix de prix du
jury au festival en allemagne
et vous vous avez eu quoi j'ai eu un
prix d'interprétation au festival
international de bombay en novembre
dernier novembre 2014 auquel participait
aussi catherine deneuve exactement
l'invité d'honneur
invitez vous avez un lien tous les deux
un faux croit malin vous avez deux
projets qui sont tournés et qui vont
sortir donc river alors entre la rentrée
et à notre film we qui s'appelle
l'éternité c'est un film réalisé par
tran anh hung
je pense que la sortie sera plutôt d'ici
un an d'accord je fais quoi
je joue le fils d'audrey tautou c'est
une grande fresque à c'est un film très
particulier très onirique vous jouez
encore quelqu'un de très jeunes
s'imaginent pas très jeune je jouais mon
âge joue ouais ouais je joue à 25 ans et
c'est un film sur toute une histoire de
famille mais ça commence au 19e siècle
ça finit aujourd'hui voilà c'est une
fresque familiale et amoureuse assez
poétique j'ai pas vu le film
oui c'est bien de l'odeur de la papaye
voilà bon alors on verra ça dans l'hiver
peut être que je pense qu'on va suivre
plutôt en tout cas maintenant qu'on sait
que vous êtes versailles agences air
chaque film exactement voilà bon on va
revenir à nos moutons à savoir le mois
molière
voilà parce que votre carrière donc elle
est donc très riche aussi bien
télévision que cinéma et de théâtre à
réels effectués par le moins beaulieu
elle est ponctuée par molière
voilà donc vous allez jouer ici donc le
molière vrai mais on n'en sait vous créé
par l'état du petit monde s'est mis en
scène par nicolas rigas soit la lettre
je joue le rôle de ra's et c'est un
spectacle
c'est un spectacle donc c'est la pièce
de molière il ya aussi de la musique en
fête l'intrigué va se passer au 19e
siècle dont qui est intégrée la musique
je la change quoi alors qu'elle soit dix
neuvième siècle
ça change qu'on n'y est que le metteur
en scène y est intégrée la musique
d'offenbach les contes d'hoffmann il a
associé en fait le personnage d'agnès
aux trois filles qui apparaissent dans
les contes d'hoffmann d'offenbach
donc on a cette musique là et puis c'est
des spectacles donc lié à la musique et
le théâtre et puis il ya aussi un duo
d'acrobates un peu clown qui font un
couple dans le film couple de danseurs
dans le film relatant un couple dans la
pièce et qui joue les deux serviteurs
donc on a c'est un peu l'esprit des
spectacles que monte nicolas rigas qui
sont très est très accessible et puis
qui qui font converger tous les tous les
métiers du spectacle vivant en fait
puisqu'on a de l'amour du théâtre comme
molière
ouais comme c'était l'esprit de molière
mais c'est de la comédie ballet c'est ça
alors à la troupe accompagné donc des
acrobates on aura un quatuor de
musiciens qui vont jouer ici donc voilà
pour la clôture du festival c'est assez
formidable
c'est magnifique et c'est la cinquième
fois je crois qu'on joue ici avoue mois
ci c'est la cinquième fois que je joue
au moins mollier on avait commencé en
2010 je crois on avait joué avec le tête
du petit monde le misanthrope
c'était en ajout ici oui oui on a fait
le misanthrope ici une maladie les
précieuses ridicules le barbier de
séville
ouais on l'a fait ici voilà dont sûr
c'est donc sur ces cinq spectacles en a
quatre qui sont des créations mois
molière d'accord vrai
du coup je vais demeurer histoire avec
versa autant quand j'étais enfant et que
me que maintenant on en a rigolé mais
c'est pour nous c'est formidable un cerf
c'est toujours le c'est là où on fait
les avant premières des spectacles avant
d'aller à avignon autour de la veille
allait passer deux saisons
a priori on se sent part en tournée et
puis ensuite on va être au festival
d'avignon en 2016
c'est le projet voilà ok bah écoutez
bravo alors à la merci
et puis peut-être à l'année prochaine
pour un match au sommet et puis si mal
et la télévision est partout voilà merci
merci oignons